[Musica]
era una sera tutti la parte più
difficile del the pixie aspettare lì
dietro ve lo dico subito perché viene
l'ansia quindi adesso iniziamo il nostro
viaggio sarà un viaggio attraverso il
sistema solare un viaggio che vi porterà
nel futuro ma un futuro che è già qui
che già qui adesso un futuro che è già
iniziato
un futuro che affonda le sue radici
nella nostra parte più intima quella di
noi uomini perché noi siamo esploratori
e quindi non possiamo fare a meno di
cercare di capire che cosa c'è là fuori
ma fuori da cosa fuori ovviamente dal
nostro pianeta il nostro pianeta il
pianeta terra
lo conosciamo è quello qui giusto per
ricordare un po tutti chi siamo un
pianeta la terra è rotonda non è piatta
ecco ricordiamocelo sempre perché c'è
ancora qualcuno che crede che la terra
sia piatta questa è un'immagine presa
dall equipaggio dell'apollo 17 nel 1972
inquadra l'africa che è il continente
dal quale tutti arriviamo si chiama blu
marble quindi una foto passata alla
storia proprio come la piccola biglia di
marmo la piccola biglia blu
questa è la nostra atmosfera guardate
come sottile eppure protegge la cosa più
importante che esiste nell'universo che
è la vita sulla terra al momento l'unica
vita che noi conosciamo
un'altra fotografia per darci un'idea di
quanto siamo piccoli noi siamo qua a
fare il pd che portiamo idee portiamo
iniziative ma guardate quel pixel
piccolino bianco sulla in basso la foto
segnato dalla freccia e il nostro
pianeta da 6 miliardi di chilometri la
sonda e la sonda voyager nel 1990 car
saga che era che è che era un astronomo
americano chiesa la nasa di girare la
sonda che stavo uscendo dal sistema
solare ancora viaggia è partita nel 77
pensate ancora lì che va fuori dal
sistema solare di girarsi a fare un
ultimo foto alla terra questo è quello
che è risultato questo piccolo pixel
bianco sul quale siamo tutti noi siamo
noi che siamo qui oggi tutte le persone
del passato tutti i voli ci saranno in
futuro siamo noi che per la terra
siamo di passaggio ovviamente quando ci
comportiamo male col nostro pianeta sono
una specie di virus dei virus su un
pixel ricordiamoci sempre che la terra
non è stata abitata sempre dall uomo
perché in passato c'erano per 120
milioni di anni
eccoli qua i dinosauri sono stati
distrutti da un asteroide e questo ci
deve far capire che noi siamo ospiti qui
sopra che la terra è qua da 4 miliardi e
mezzo di anni sarà poi per altrettanto
tempo e noi siamo qua tutto sommato da 3
milioni di anni più o meno grazie
all'estinzione dei dinosauri è
sopravvissuto il dinosauro continua a
essere qui adesso lo facciamo andare via
un piccolo ratto un topo che sarebbe
secondo alcuni uno dei nostri antenati
l'unico mammifero che sopravvisse
l'estinzione dei dinosauri da più arrivò
poi anche tutta la serie dei mammiferi
la scimmia e poi l'uomo eccolo qua a
l'uomo sapiens 300 mila anni fa più o
meno non è molto bello questo perché
insomma ci siamo un po deprimendo quindi
ci consoliamo con l'ultimo anello della
catena evolutiva
eccolo qua beckham che scusatemi insomma
lo dico avessi le foto di tutti i
signori uomini che sono qua li avrei
messi ma non li avevo quindi ho scelto
beccano insomma come anello positivo ma
come tutti noi che siamo ospiti prima o
poi da questo pianeta ce ne dovremmo
andare e poi mi cerchiamo di capire dove
possiamo andare la terra un minimo di
ripasso di astronomia per capire dove
siamo la terra eccolo qua e fa parte dei
pianeti rocciosi sono i pianeti interni
del sistema solare più vicini al sole
mercurio venere la terra e marte
i veneti esterni sono gli amati giganti
gassosi e poi i giganti di ghiaccio
urano e nettuno la terra si trova a
insieme a venere e marte quella che è
chiamata la fascia di abitabilità e
importante dobbiamo capire perché è così
importante perché è la fascia attorno a
una stella in cui l'acqua rimane allo
stato liquido non è troppo vicina per
evaporare non è troppo lontana per
viaggiare l'acqua lo stato liquido ci
serve perché nell'acqua che si è
sviluppata la vita e dall'acqua che noi
arriviamo e quindi sono e cerchiamo vita
o cerchiamo un posto in cui potremmo
comunque andare un qualche cosa che ci
aiuta a sopravvivere a dobbiamo cercare
l'acqua perché perché sicuramente per
qualche motivo ce ne sono tanti
fra un po di tempo saremmo costretti ad
andare via volenti o nolenti da questo
pianeta
un ultimo il sole però miliardo di anni
la nostra stella che nei campi più o
meno 8 miliardi 4 miliardi e ha già
passati altri quattro li vivrà però
famiglia
il sole inizierà a cambiare il proprio a
elaborare il proprio combustibile
aumenterà di luminosità la terra
aumenterà di temperatura ci friggere mo
un pochettino tutti però abbiamo un
miliardo di anni per pensarci quindi in
un miliardo di anni magari riusciremo a
costruire l'enterprise ed essere già in
qualche altra galassia parallela chi lo
sa a sfidare la relatività un motivo
molto più vicino invece è il prossimo
eccolo qua gli asteroidi un asteroide ha
distrutto la vita sulla terra ha portato
la una delle più grandi estinzioni
quella dei dinosauri 65 milioni di anni
fa secondo la statistica asteroidi di
questo genere arrivano ogni 10 milioni
di anni
purtroppo ne sono passati 65 milioni è
l'evento potrebbe essere vicino tutto
sotto controllo la nasa e l'esa
l'agenzia spaziale europea hanno un
sistema di controllo di tutti questi
asteroidi che girano attorno alla terra
però noi potrebbe arrivare qualcuno
l'ultimo motivo perché di macchie pieno
il mondo ne abbiamo avuto dimostrazione
purtroppo ultimamente c'è il rischio di
una guerra globale una guerra planetaria
un'epidemia la sovrapopolazione oppure
appunto semplicemente che abbiamo voglia
di andarsene dalla terra quindi se ne
dovremmo andare dove andiamo
abbiamo visto venere e marte venere
troppo calda moriremmo marte è il
pianeta considerato il pianeta gemello
della terra e non è una un'idea campata
per aria licenziate hanno scoperto che
in passato marte era proprio come la
terra adesso non le più ha perso la
propria atmosfera non c'è più l'acqua è
un pianeta più o meno vedete la metà
della terra
la temperatura un pò freddino perché è
molto più lontano dal sole rispetto alla
terra meno 55 gradi ma la superficie più
o meno siamo attorno ai 20 quando
illuminata dal sole
il suono dura il doppio dell'anno della
terra la sua giornata più o meno lunga
come la nostra una cosa importante però
su marte c'è l'acqua non c'è l'acqua in
superficie e ricorderete sicuramente i
famosi canali di marte sono stati al tt
corsi d'acqua per qualche motivo che
ancora non sappiamo è sparito tutto ma
l'acqua rimasta nel sottosuolo
eccola qua congelata ghiacciata la
stiamo l'abbiamo vista e potremmo
utilizzarla in futuro se vogliamo andare
in qualche modo a vivere su marte ci
sono però tanti problemi
eccoli qua i nostri astronauti sulla
stazione spaziale internazionale che
quella che vedete
in alto a destra stanno cercando di
capire come possiamo fare noi uomini
nati sulla terra cresciuti sulla terra
evoluti sulla terra quindi con una certa
gravità una certa atmosfera una certa
luce strutturati in un certo modo come
possiamo farla diventare spaziali perché
per arrivare su marte ci vorranno ci
vogliono più o meno tre anni fa andare e
tornare ma che non vogliamo andare solo
restare lì e ci vogliono più o meno dai
sei agli otto mesi 8 6 8 mesi andare se
otto mesi a tornare due anni per
aspettare che i pianeti nella loro
orbita attorno al sole si riallineano
per poterci permettere di fare il
viaggio più corto possibile i nostri
astronauti queste luca parmitano
parlavamo ragazza di catena evolutiva
abbiamo degli astronauti veramente in
gamba eccolo qui prestano il loro corpo
sono le cavie sono loro che prestano il
loro fisico agli esperimenti della dei
nostri medici sulla terra non solo per
capire come l'uomo fa diventare spaziale
in microgravità sulla stazione spaziale
internazionale che non è assenza di
gravità tale tecnica e microgravità
l'effetto più o meno lo stesso la
gravità non aiuta più il sangue a
circolare il si gonfia il viso il
cervello che migliorato in maniera
diversa
cambia l'udito cambia l'ho fatto cambia
il gusto quindi il nostro corpo subisce
tutta una serie di trasformazioni che
sono importanti per due motivi per
capire come farla diventare spaziali ma
soprattutto e questo importante saperlo
sempre per capire quali sono le
patologie che noi possiamo curare perché
nello spazio tutto è amplificato e
quindi l'osteoporosi le malattie
degenerative dei muscoli delle ossa si
sviluppano molto più in fretta quindi
dallo spazio noi possiamo aiutare a
stare molto meglio sulla terra per
diventare spaziali
quindi ci vorrà un lungo percorso anche
perché un altro dei rischi dello spazio
e questa la terra è coperta come un
guscio ma un guscio protettivo che si
chiama magnetosfera ci protegge da dei
raggi che ucciderebbero in pochissime
settimane che arrivano dal sole è che
arrivano dall universo anche qua
dobbiamo cercare un modo per arrivare
fino a marte per proteggerci sulla sua
superficie
eccolo qui si costruiranno città su
marte questo è vero si costruiranno
sotto terra perché non c'è l'atmosfera
la dobbiamo creare sotto terra perché i
raggi cosmici ucciderebbero ecco qui
allora in arrivo
una tecnologia molto importante
sviluppata da qualche anno che nello
spazio a ben presente
ed ecco il qui e ora dello spazio ecco
perché lo spaccio aiuta la terra
la stampante 3d si stamperanno i
villaggi marziani e villaggi lunari che
vedremo tra pochissimo anche sulla luna
dove non abiteremo ma saranno colonia
grazie alle stampanti 3d sottoterra
potremmo coltivare le verdure guardate
queste serre ne parleremo tra pochissimo
perché è perché il cibo un altro dei
grossi problemi che noi dovremo
affrontare per andare nello spazio
questo è un simulacro di villaggio
lunare è già stato costruito un pezzo di
villaggio lunare sulla terra si trova in
olanda nella sede dell'agenzia spaziale
europea
ho potuto vederla e toccarla di
un'emozione grandissima costruite con
materiali che si trovano in loco con le
stampanti 3d quindi anche questo
costruiamo sulla luna ma lo utilizziamo
anche per aiutare a costruire sulla
terra in tempi brevi in tempi veloci le
tecnologie ancora sono da sviluppare ma
arriveranno ne abbiamo fiducia in questo
parliamo del cibo eccolo qua non
possiamo portarci sull'astronave una
scorta di cibo per tre anni a mano che
di saccheggiare tutti i supermercati del
pianeta andrebbe a male e soprattutto
portare un chilo di materia nello spazio
costa migliaia di dollari ogni chilo
viene trasportiamo bisogna farselo in
orbita fino a che non scopriremo come
portare le mucche su marte dobbiamo
accontentarci delle verdure e c'è un
progetto che siamo vecchi sulla stazione
spaziale internazionale coltivano
verdure in assenza di gravità
non c'è la gravità a dire alle verdure
dove metterle radice dove mettere le
foglie sulla terra c'è ma si è visto che
le verdure reagiscono benissimo se
vengono coltivate in acqua queste serre
utilizzate nello spazio sono utilissime
sulla terra per portare il cibo nelle
zone più difficili mezzo ai deserti o
nei ghiacciai dell'antartide e anche
questo è un altro esempio di come lo
spazio aiuta la terra i nostri
astronauti l'hanno mangiata questi
insalate dicono che sono molto buone
certo non possono condirle come
farebbero sulla terra perché nello
spazio tutto galleggia quindi niente
olio però anche questo è un primo passo
per potere poi coltivare per poterle poi
coltivare su marte queste saranno le
città marziane cupole che proteggono
questo è un esempio di città gli arabi
il emirati arabi e non hanno annunciato
che nel 2017
avranno la loro prima città su marte per
avere una città su marte nel 1117 durerà
che prima siamo arrivati ma come
facciamo ad arrivare su marte questo un
grossissimo problema perché non esiste
sulla terra al momento nessun razzo così
potente che ci possa portare su marte in
tempi brevi e con un consumo di
carburante esiguo che è un altro dei
grossissimi problemi c'è un'idea però
c'è stato un imprenditore illuminato una
persona molto particolare le agenzie
spaziali lavorano a pieno ritmo su
questo ma il primo ad arrivare ad
annunciare che sarebbe andato su marte è
fatto un imprenditore lui si chiama
eccolo qui elon musk
lui è il proprietario e fondatore di
paypal
per chi non lo conosce il proprietario
della ten se la lui ha detto qualche
anno fa io porterò entro il 2030 gli
uomini su marte l'ha detto e l'ha fatto
ha fatto un sacco di errori ma ha
costruito un razzo molto particolare che
si chiama folk online
eccolo qui lo vediamo intanto che
decolla è speciale perché perché decolla
guardate che cosa fa la differenza di
tutti gli altri razzi
non viene distrutto completamente e si
perde tutto il razzo il primo stadio
torna indietro
torna indietro eri alterna è a terra da
solo ovviamente i primi anni si
distruggeva adesso è riuscito a farla
atterrare benissimo tanto che il primo
che si serve dei razzi di hamas che
proprio la nasa che era stata alla più
incredula da questo annuncio e questo
sarà il sistema che permette di
abbattere i costi perché come un aereo
li rimette il carburante e razzo riparte
perché dico che il primo passo per marte
per quello annunciato entro breve un
altro decollo questo è il fratello
grandissimo sarà il razzo ti porterà
veramente gli uomini su marte è
veramente enorme e si chiama iphone rock
e di un altro anche questa che sfrutta
lo stesso principio ritorna indietro si
ricarica prende il carburante intanto ci
sono tre quattrocento persone
nell'attesa va versata perfino
non atterrano su un alter ego storaggio
è anche capace di ripartire a meno che
non voglia stare lì e questo il modo con
cui porteremo gli uomini su marte il
famoso tetto non esiste ma per parlarvi
di futuro che cosa succede
il 6 febbraio del 2018 pochi mesi fa è
iniziato questo futuro questo perché il
futuro è adesso è già iniziato quella
sera sulla rampa di lancio che pena vera
nel famoso pad 39a c'era questo il
falcon heavy tre primi stati come il
falcon 9 che avete visto prima un
decollo da questa rampa celebre perché
tali sono partite tutte le missioni
apollo questo falcone vi è il fratello
piccolo del bfr e se avesse funzionato
questo decollo si sarebbe aperta la
strada per arrivare a marte il 6
febbraio eccoci qua l'italia che è un
paese notoriamente proiettato al futuro
tutto il mondo stava guardando questo
decolli ho messo davanti alla
televisione
proiettandoci grazie alla smart tv
online
c'erano 22 milioni di persone ci ho
messo i miei figli il cane il gatto che
scappavano ore sono tutti lì a guardare
l'italia oltre 22.000 e di persone che
guardavano lei questo stava organizzando
la celebrazione con l'associazione
garibaldini per l'italia o 11 milioni
stavano guardando il festival di sanremo
con tutto il rispetto per i garibaldini
che hanno fatto questo paese per sanremo
il futuro in quel momento era da
un'altra parte l'italia non ne aveva la
minima idea perché guardate cosa è
successo quella sera alle 9 45 di sera
questo razzo è decollato tutti pensavano
che esplodesse nel primo minuto di
lancio
lo stesso e lo mas che temeva che
succedesse questo invece il razzo ha
fatto il suo dovere e guardate
l'entusiasmo 150.000 persone stavano a
cap canaveral in quel momento è che
abbiamo aggiunto le loro reazioni in
questo video guardate un attimo se parte
dai 16 un po
[Musica]
[Applauso]
dimmi
[Musica]
questi sono tutti quanti sono i due
stadi che si staccano dai materani
e anche perché lo dice la rinascente
parla di tutti noi credevamo comune e le
materie sul web
[Musica]
l'alternanza guardato sembra grafica non
è vero
era successo un polmone
se ho visti six esultano ovviamente
perché tutti pensavano che questa
impresa sarebbe andata malissimo e
questo è il primo passo verso il futuro
e un futuro che però bisogna costruire
tutti insieme perché elon musk a un
imprenditore quindi rischia di sumo per
arrivare su marte come tutto quello che
spaccia come lo spazio insegna come
insegna la stazione spaziale
internazionale
bisogna collaborare tutti insieme
bisogna unire i paesi e in quel momento
riusciremo a fare questo grande passo la
nostra voglia di esplorare ci porterà
veramente nello spazio che ti sta
sfidando ci sta chiamando dall'alba
dell'umanità vi lascio con l'ultimo
video e quello è un riassunto di quella
giornata perché dentro l'ogiva di quel
razzo c'era il primo astronauta il primo
uomo era nostro nato il manichino
si chiama starmene che sarebbe arrivato
che sfiorerà la superficie di marte che
per milioni di anni
girerà fra il sole e marte a bordo di
che cosa di una tessera la tesla rossa
di allen must che lui ha voluto che
fosse la prima auto il primo la prima
astronave per marte e la completa un
pagamento una musica particolarissima
che racconta della vita dell'uomo su
marte ed è life on mars di david bowie
vi lascio con questo video
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ma ci attende
però si può
claire
[Musica]
insomma
si no
no
[Musica]
la mamma
[Applauso]
[Musica]
no
grazie
[Applauso]